My name is Shaina Mehta and I am the
2018 Spring Sing Executive Director.
So as the director my role is to manage and oversee the entire planning process of
Spring Sing from start to finish so
right now our production team is just
finishing up screwing on the lights to
our truss and in a few minutes they're
gonna raise that truss all the way up to
the ceiling after that we're gonna start
building our stage and once our stage is
complete we're gonna put out chairs all
on the floor and then after that we're
gonna just finish up and make sure Pauley
is all ready to go. This year we have
15 acts all of our groups practice in
various places a lot of our bigger dance
groups will practice in parking lot 4
or reserved spaces in Wooden or even
anywhere on campus so it's really a
range of places that the students get
together and work hard to make their
piece show ready we have groups
rehearsing til 4 a.m. sometimes and
really putting their all into this show.
During our show week we have tech
rehearsals and a dress rehearsal here in Pauley Pavilion and then we also have Company
who is our comedic troupe that helps us
to transition the show and emcee yeah
they sing they dance they put together
both live skits and prepare an array of
videos that get played during the show
they're awesome they're really
high-quality they're really funny so
I got like 14 hours of sleep last night
and took a six-hour now and then we also
have stage crews who are our Bruins who
help us put this all together and make
it possible by building the stage and
making sure everything runs smoothly
backstage. It has been the best
experience of my UCLA career.